aux etats unis toujours le missouri a
décidé de porter plainte contre la chine
eric schmidt le procureur général de cet
état de plus de six millions d'habitants
a déposé une plainte au civil c'était
mardi la cus pékin d'avoir dissimulé la
gravité de l'épidémie
ducobu de 19 les accusations démenties
par la chine le missouri déplore 177
morts liés aux convives 19 et des
milliards de dollars de pertes
on voit cela avec emilie gogh h une
plainte qui vise directement le
gouvernement chinois
le parti communiste mais aussi d'autres
hauts responsables et institutions du
pays
selon eric schmidt pékin a dissimulé des
informations capitales et laissez-le
coronavirus se propager avant de prendre
les mesures nécessaires durant les
premières semaines de l'épidémie les
autorités chinoises ont trompé le public
censurer des informations cruciales
arrêter des danseurs d'alert nier la
transmission entre humains malgré des
preuves de plus en plus nombreuse
détruit des recherches médicales vitales
laissé des millions de personnes sont
exposées au virus et même garder en
stock des équipements de protection
provoquant ainsi une pandémie inutiles
que l'on aurait pu empêcher des
accusations démenties par la diplomatie
chinoise son porte parole les qualifie
de malveillantes et abusive pour game
chang le gouvernement chinois a toujours
partagé ces informations
cette soi-disant accusation qui n'a
aucune base factuelle et juridique est
absurde
le gouvernement chinois a toujours
adopté une attitude ouverte transparente
et responsable
il a informé en temps utile oms et les
pays et régions concernées y compris les
états unis en leur communiquant
plusieurs séries d'informations il a
répondu activement aux préoccupations de
toutes les parties et il a renforcé la
coopération avec la communauté
internationale
il y a quelques jours donald trump a lui
accusé la chine de cacher le véritable
bilan de l'épidémie est qu'un a
fermement démenti d'autres chefs d'état
et de gouvernement ont demandé aux
chinois plus de clarté le président
français emmanuel macron a fait part de
ses doutes sur la transparence
revendiquée par les autorités chinoises
en allemagne
la chancelière fédérale angela merkel a
elle demandé à pékin de faire la lumière
sur l'origine de la pandémie